having marked a century since the end of
the great war of 1914 18 we now mark the
75th anniversary of the official end of
the 1939-45 war in Europe generally
known as VE Day the 8th of May 1945 was
the Allies formal acceptance of Nazi
Germany's unconditional surrender after
six years of conflict the British were
keen to party and countless numbers took
to the streets crowds massed in
Trafalgar Square the man and outside
Buckingham Palace where King George the
6th and Queen Elizabeth the Winston
Churchill appeared on the balcony in
London alone two and a half million teas
and lemonade's were consumed two million
sandwiches and 1.2 million buns there
was a general air of joy and relief and
this was not just restricted to the
Capitol here in Malden
locals had experienced the impact of the
hostilities firsthand loved ones had
gone off to fight some of them never to
return there are 86 names on our towns
war memorial alone locals did their bit
in the Civil Defence services they
experienced the hardships of rationing
some of that rationing would continue
until 1954 and air raids have been a
regular feature of life and death
there were 14 fatalities in Malden and
Highbridge and they've been so much more
going on besides so when they heard the
prime minister's broadcast on their
primitive crystal wireless sets and
realized that the blackouts could at
large long last come down that there'll
be no further need for them to rush to
their Morrison shelters they knew that
this really was their victory as
Churchill told them in all our long
history we've never seen a greater day
than this the residents of individual
streets in Malden Burnham and all across
the surrounding village
hurriedly made plans to put up bunting
and flags and to roll down a barrel or
two to capture the moment for fear that
it was only a dream supplies were pulled
an imaginative feasts were concocted
spam fritters and powdered eggs were
very much in evidence and then there
were the famous Walton pies named after
Lord Walton the minister of food and
consisting of vegetables in a brown
flour marjorine pastry moistened with
Bovril gravy
there were parties bonfires including a
massive one on the promenade which burnt
all night and dancing not least outside
of the Swan Hotel in Milton's High
Street the modern pubs ignored all of
the licensing hours and they were packed
but there was no trouble at all and one
particular participant remembers it was
a delightful day and one which I will
always remember and talking about
remembering and remembrance we must rely
very heavily on personal accounts of
what happened that day because it seems
that very few official records survived
photographs do however capture the
moment and there are some wonderful
pictures of the partygoers in places
like Fitch's Crescent
North streets and outside what was then
the Salvation Army Hall now the mosque
in wilden's Church Street when you look
at those pictures some of the adults are
wearing black respecting the absence of
husbands and sweethearts who made the
ultimate sacrifice on this the 75th
anniversary of d-day whilst we've not
been able to mark the event across the
district and as we'd originally planned
I hope that you will still take some
time to join in on the many online
activities to mark this very special
occasion 75 years since VE Day 75 years
of peace
we meet again don't know
[Music]